everybody uh I'm Rabbi Jim Panet the
Howard M Holzman Jewish chaplain at Yale
I wish to welcome you all here uh for an
event that we've called reality check an
examination of anti-Semitism in 2014 uh
this event is co-sponsored by the United
States Department of State uh and the Y
program for the study of
anti-Semitism um we'll be listening uh
today to uh two people in public
conversation that I'll try not to
interrupt um Iris Ira Foreman who was
sworn in as the special Envoy to Monitor
and combat anti-Semitism on May 20th
2013 uh prior to that he served as the
Jewish Outreach director for the Obama
uh for the Obama campaign for the Obama
for America campaign IRA has a long and
distinguished history of working in the
Jewish communal work uh in public
service sector he served for nearly 15
years as the executive director of the
National Jewish Democratic Council he
also worked at the American Israel
public affairs committee where he worked
as political director and legislative
leaone he was the director of
congressional relations for the office
of personnel management throughout his
career he has spoken and written
extensively on Jewish history and public
policy Mr Foreman also co-edited and
wrote for the uh ref for the reference
book Jews in American politics and I
should note due to no fault of his own
he is a graduate of Harvard
University royya haki and is known to
many of us here in New Haven um poet
author human rights activist one of the
found ERS of the uh uh founding member
of the Iran human rights Documentation
Center a fellow at the Whitney Humanity
Center here at Yale University um this
uh discussion uh will be uh streamed
live and um uh there are people here who
can fill in cards to ask questions I
think the cards have been passed out to
you send them down over here to Kanan
who will uh bring them uh bring them to
my attention uh we are also able to
receive questions via Twitter um the
event is streamed at humanrights.gov
stateof rights um using # stateof rights
you can ask questions that will be
received here and I will uh call them uh
as they appear um thought it appropriate
to begin uh with our special Envoy um uh
to Monitor and combat anti-Semitism the
third person to fill that job uh Ira
form and I'm guessing Ira that uh most
people don't even know that the United
States Department has an office of a
special Envoy uh to Monitor and combat
anti-Semitism can you tell us something
about the history of your office what
you do and uh how it feels since you've
been in place since May well certainly
though I want to start by thanking the
El program for the study of
anti-Semitism uh the one thing I have
learned in a year in this job is the
issue of worldwide anti-Semitism is
incredibly complex and to have an
academic institution of Yale's quality
uh studying this topic is critical for
us to ever get a handle on how to really
in any way combat uh this kind of
scourge and I'm also honored to be on
the program with royya hakakian who is
uh such an accomplished individual and
um look forward to her remarks but yes
uh I and every time I speak about this
program my ask my audience do you know
that the state department even does this
and the answer is invariably 2/3 to 90%
say no of course not uh but but this
program has been this office was created
by act of Congress in 2004 uh and uh
though many of you know when we hear
about things happening in Congress most
often we hear of uh great partisan
divides and I will say in the year I've
been in this office and when this
legislation went through it was unique
in the sense there are no partisan
divides here this is an issue uh one of
the few issues certainly that uh both
both Democrats and Republicans uh at the
time in 2004 when it was bipartisanly
co-sponsored uh by former Congressman
Tom Lantos current Congressman Chris
Smith uh former Senator Jame uh voyavich
George voinovich uh tremendous
bipartisan support uh and there uh the
office was actually set up two years
later in 2006 uh and it is sily unique
only to my awareness only isra
has a comparable in their foreign office
foreign Ministry has a comparable office
that is actually targeting directly
anti-Semitism uh and the title special
Envoy to Monitor and combat
anti-Semitism is essentially what the
office is all about uh the monitoring is
actually quite direct the state
department every year issues both a
human rights report which was issued in
March of this year and an international
religious Freedom report which usually
follows in the following months uh and
we hope to have out very soon and but in
addition to that where we do monitor in
over 60 countries uh an anti-Semitism is
part of those reports in addition we are
collecting data from around the world uh
places like the caner center Tel Aviv
University uh data that simply like the
ADL survey that just recently came out
but the other piece of our office is
travel around the world to talk to Jew
members of the Jewish Community talk to
governments talk to NOS about this
problem so there's a number of ways we
can monitor the combating side is more
difficult uh how do you combat a problem
as I mentioned so complex so different
in many ways in different parts of the
world so many different manifestations
of
anti-Semitism so we have tools of
private diplomacy we have tools of
public
diplomacy uh I believe it's really
really important why this type of
meaning is so important is to bring in
other stakeholders Jewish Community
stakeholders non-jewish stakeholders
communities other governments because
the problem will not be addressed in any
sufficient way without a multipe of
people so we spend a lot of time
outreaching uh to other groups other
governments to talk about what we can do
together um and of course part of our
job to bring this whole issue up to the
top of the state department to our uh
most important diplomats including
secretary kry and the White House and
the president uh when we think that uh
these issues need to come up to that uh
that level and we increasingly
unfortunately have to uh make those
reports more and more often thank you
Ira um there's U there's much more I
want to ask you but I thought to bring
you in right away um my dear Roya um uh
Roya uh born in Iran wrote a a mem some
years ago called the land of no did I
say that Journey from the the journey
from the land of no um about your
experience there and you have a unique
sense of I would almost characterize it
as a um well it's a love relationship
that has serious critique in it
regarding Iran in other words it's not
simply a story of anti-Semitism not at
all no in fact um um well I'm delighted
to be part of this panel and honored uh
to be next to my spiritual leader um and
and Ira um I um specifically wrote the
book because I thought that U Iran was
misunderstood and um and part of that
that misunderstanding is that the notion
of Iran uh being equal or the experience
of more my experience of uh being a Jew
in Iran being a young person in Iran at
a revolutionary era um was somehow uh
synonymous or written off as um
the same as the leadership that
represented Iran and I think that's
really where what I want to leave with
um our audiences today if nothing else
that um we pay a lot of lip service to
the notion that we U shouldn't assume
that the Iranian Nation or or any Nation
Under a tyranny is U equal to its regime
that regimes cannot represent Nations
under those circumstances and it's
certainly true about Iran and that
that's what um my book tried to capture
so in other words I think um I think the
best way of uh summarizing the
experience is that the the Iranian
regime happens to be far more backward
than than the Iranian nation
that that while for instance the
previous president Ahmed inad was going
around the world U trying to uh really
warmonger and hate Monger by denying the
Holocaust and and uh claiming that he
that he intended to wipe Israel off the
map um or whatever that translation was
because there was a great deal of
discussion whether or not the
translation from Persian um into English
was correct um Iranians themselves had
um are vastly different and as a result
of the government's radical um
anti-israeli and
anti-semitic uh positions um have have
stood actually to the opposite of the
regime and that's I think the most
important point that is often lost as we
watch the nuclear discussion as we um
begin to worry about um the propaganda
coming out of Iran that um while while
the regime uh creates this Mayhem uh
especially within um the media realm uh
that the nation is going in fact the
opposite in the opposite direction
and um when you look at the leadership
of Iran there is a great deal to worry
about but when you take a look at the
35-year movement of the Iranian people
in terms of their relationship to Israel
views of Jews and all that Iranians are
probably um the only nation in the
region who have uh taken a step away in
a completely independent and unique
Direction in that region and I think I'm
I'm glad that the representative of
Anti-Defamation League is here today
because um they their recent survey
backs up my claims uh which I
desperately needed because I've been
making this argument for several years
and No One Believes Me everybody
referred to me as you know a nostalgic
Exile who wanted to put a good face on
on the Iranian nation that that she
misses but but in fact um I'm glad to
see that Anti-Defamation League has
produced a survey that that uh pretty
much makes these remarks uh valid and we
can go over them in in subsequent
questions thank you Roy for that that
that leads to a question that's
pertinent to your portfolio iron that is
uh it has been observed that the new
anti-Semitism today is uh cloaks itself
in anti-zionist uh anti-israel critique
um and uh I'm certain you've seen that
phenomenon the question I think is uh uh
how you sort that out surely criticism
of every state is uh uh legitimate and
perhaps necessary
um uh are you able to your own
satisfaction uh thus far to distinguish
an anti-semitic attack on the state of
Israel from uh uh from a legitimate uh
critique of the state of Israel well uh
Rabbi that's an excellent question and
uh I don't have a perfect answer I
wouldn't think so it's a hard one I know
there are some fuzzy lines and uh the
whole question of what is anti-Semitic
uh is not always clear sometimes is but
uh in terms terms of US policy certainly
the we would like to have Israel treated
exactly like all other nations so that
means criticism of Israel is legitimate
like criticism of other nations it also
means sometimes that even criticism we
may not agree with is
legitimate question is where is it cross
the line and from a US perspective uh we
have some kind of markers they're not
perfect but they give us some really
good uh Direction and the first first is
is that criticism delegitimizing Israel
is it making the case that Israel has no
right to exist is it making the case
that Zionism is the only form of
nationalism that's illegitimate when
that's the case that's certainly is
crossed the
line it also is crosses the line uh from
US policy
perspective uh when Israel is defamed so
for example if someone says I don't like
what Israel is doing doing with
Palestinians and the West Bank that's
not necessarily anti-Semitism at all but
if someone says what Israel is doing to
the Palestinians is exactly what the
Nazis did to Jews that's cross the line
def
defamation and finally when we have
clear clear signs of double standards we
treat Israel very different than we
treat other
places often in uh sometimes in un
agencies ET we see this that crosses the
line that crosses the line when Israel
is
criticized uh for say human rights
violations uh time and time and time
again and States like the North Koreans
the Iranians the syrians are never even
mentioned that's illegitimate so yes uh
uh that's those are kind of the
guidelines we use uh how the rubber
Meats aad sometimes a little more
difficult
uh sometimes it may not be useful to use
the term
anti-Semitism sometimes we deal with
issues that we would CL classify that
are not anti-Semitism and I'll give you
one example we're working on right now
and that's the issue uh in parts of
Europe of attempts to ban
circumcision um we have parts of Civil
Society we have political actors in
parts of Northern Europe some of the
German speaking parts of Europe saying
we should ban
circumcision now we address this because
the people who usually say this usually
speak about children's autonomy so we
talk about this as an issue Paramount of
religious freedom and that uh
circumcision uh is a religious ritual
for not just Jews but also Muslims is an
issue of religious freedom so um again
it's a complex issue but there are
definite red lines and we try to call
them
out thank you for that helpful and and
appreciate that it's difficult and
you're you're new in your task still
finding your way and uh um Roy you made
a distinction I'd be interested uh Ira
in your reaction to that between the
regime and the people um specifically as
regards Iran to kind of deepen the
possibility for you addressing that
distinction royya maybe you could say
something about uh um the state of
Iranian jewry today know was as I as I
understand we all know there's been
there was a massive flight in the
primarily in the ' 50s and and through
the 60s of Jews from uh Arab and Middle
Eastern and Northern African uh
communities where they had lived for
centuries none older than the Jewish
community of Iran U most of those
communities have next to no Jews left
Baghdad I think maybe has a handful um
how many Jews live today in uh in
tan well the problem with all Iranian
communities even in the United States is
that it's it's held to get statistics
from them because you're talking about a
population that has never learned or
wanted or had any reason to collaborate
with the authorities so even Iranians in
California today are reluctant to
participate in census taking and and all
sorts of you know U uh efforts such as
this so it's very difficult with Iranian
communities in or outside of Iran um
when it comes to U taking numbers U but
but it's particularly more difficult in
Iran today because the Iranian Jewish
Community has uh to my to my great uh
dismay and sadness has gone back to what
it used to know so we had a period in
Iran that my father very eloquently
speaks about where uh Jews were better
off staying hidden or being
unrecognizable from the general
population and then um during the the uh
reign of Ros shaal and and his son
Muhammad Rah pavi um Jews left the
ghettos and they became visible citizens
so you could recognize um you know
Iranian Jews and it was okay um because
Iran was um was becoming far more U
eclectic in terms of its um religious
and ethnic um makeup and um accepting
minorities within the fabric of the
society was was very much uh part of
that regime was all about in creating uh
one
common Nation but then um the Jews today
um even though they uh the Jewish
Community was recognized uh as a
legitimate community and ayatollahi
himself u a few weeks after the Iranian
Revolution in February of
1979 um said publicly that the Jews were
welcome to stay in Iran because they
were people of the book um they have
gone back to the old mode of of re um
retreating to the hidden Jewish mode
that they knew before the Revolution so
taking censes within Iran is very
difficult um there are prior to the
Iranian Revolution there was anywhere
between 100 to 120,000 Jews living in
Iran um and I have heard statistics um
that that place that number today to uh
less than a quarter uh of that number so
anywhere from 10,000 to 20,000 seem to
be remaining in Iran however it it's a
reporting on this community is extremely
difficult and I don't know of a single
journalist who has done a good job of of
uh going into Iran uh interviewing or
talking to people and coming back with a
proper and balanced um Peace are the do
we know whe whether the Iranian Jewish
Community is free to immigrate today or
are there constraints of on their travel
so um there was never officially a ban
on the department of the Jews but but
that's um so what what interests me in
in the history of contemporary Iranian
Jews in Iran isn't isn't simply that uh
my own background as Jewish but but I
think anybody who's interested in Iran
or the Middle East would learn a great
deal about how this regime is operating
by the way they're dealing with the
Jewish Community this is part of what
motivates you to want to establish here
at Yale if possible uh an Iranian Jewish
uh archive is that right thank you for
that plug M you're welcome um
yes I I think that um of course it's of
interest to to collect the history of
Iranian jewelry but but it should be of
interest to anybody who wants to study
the Middle East and and the behavior of
the Contemporary this current regime in
Iran to watch the way in which the
regime treats the Jewish Community now
to go back to your original question the
regime never officially
banned um Jews from leaving but the
regime never officially allowed Jews to
leave either so so this is how um it it
behaves in every possible way um on on
critical questions is Iran developing
nuclear
weapons you know you come away from one
nuclear negotiations maybe not then you
go home and you you get intelligence
from ground that maybe they are so so it
this is this is I think the way that the
regime has allowed um this so many
things to fall into a shadowy un
uncertain gray area has been basically
the the regime's modus operand and the
the reason the regime continues to
survive because you never know there is
no definite answer so when I
left Iran in
1984 uh Jews were not officially banned
from leaving but when we applied um for
our passports to be
renewed um uh and and get turned our
passports in our passports were
confiscated
and when we asked when we can pick them
up they said come back in 6 months so
when we returned in 6
months we had to come back another six
months so rather than saying we're not
giving you your passports they were
saying you have to wait six months and
and each time the six months were
prolonged um until
that it wasn't until then that the
Jewish community and and other religious
minorities in Iran it's not it's not to
say that the Jewish Community is
actually the worst off religious
minority in Iran in fact the bahai
community is doing far worse uh and and
is being severely persecuted to to the
point that Jews have never known in
post-revolutionary Iran um but but since
Jews are the topic of discussion today
um the Jewish Community realized that uh
the passport applications had been
altered uh after the rise of the new
regime and one question that didn't used
to exist on passport applications was
the question of religion
religion had been added and people um
started to Simply respond to it
truthfully and uh until uh we realized
that you know maybe we should be
responding truthfully um to to the
question of religion and um and so we
found uh corrupt people within the
passport office who could be bribed and
you know swap the initial act
applications with the truthful responses
to the question of religion to
um altered applications which is what I
did um I left as an Armenian um my
original application was eventually
swapped um and and and I think some of
this continues to go on so um it's
easier today to leave Iran if you're
Jewish than it was when I left Iran um
and part of that has to do with the fact
that the regime is far more secure and
mature in its evolutionary or
developmental stages of life um but back
then it was uh far more insecure and had
a harder time allowing people to uh to
leave it's it's easier now but it's um
but there are no uh official positions
and they can always uh tell you to come
back in six months so uh thank you for
that word so the distinction between the
regime and the and the uh local
population the millions that live there
seems to matter significantly as we
evaluate Iran Ira but I'm I'm thinking
come to Europe uh come say to France
where uh official state policy is uh
very concerned about issues of
anti-Semitism and yet the local Jewish
Community to the best of my reading uh
is terribly upset um feels itself
endangered um uh so is the distinction
between what the regime says and what's
actually going on in a country one that
is important for uh the state department
in general and for yourself and your
particular role as Envoy to CH to uh
Monitor and combat anti-semitism
to
consider well as I'm listening to Roya
um there are issues are coming up that I
that I we haven't wrestled with now we
always look uh first in our office at
what is actually happening on the ground
what are Jew Jews themselves saying what
are they doing in terms of immigration
uh we had a survey that came out last
year from the fundamental rights agency
of the EU uh of eight Jewish communities
in the EU
and one of the shocking things is that
in France 46% of Jews have thought of
immigrating uh not for economic reasons
but before because of the situation as
relates to
anti-Semitism that's uh that that number
in Hungary is
48% and that uh we've actually seen
another uh in France another survey just
this last month that actually said those
numbers might be even
higher uh and uh that is that's the
first thing we look at but of course you
have to look at what the government
itself is doing and I think uh Rabbi
you're exactly right when you say that
the as far as I've seen the French
government knows what's happening
they're extremely concerned they are
taking uh various measures I don't think
they know and I'm not sure we know
exactly what's going to solve the this
problem it's a quite it's a it actually
affects much more of their society than
just the the viability of their Jewish
community and that fundamentally the
viability of these communities the
pressure they're feeling is our first
priority you go to other countries in
Europe uh and again I think we should
make the distinction you go back to the
inner War period you had a number of
governments I think you would classify
clearly besides Nazi Germany as
anti-semitic I think it's much more
difficult to say that about any
government in Europe at least in uh uh
the the governments that we deal with
with significant ific Jewish populations
in Europe but that doesn't mean they're
not they similar to France in some of a
understanding what's going on be willing
to take steps to try uh and put
resources to changing that and often
often and really important I I found
confronting history when you have
regimes that don't want to confront what
really H has happened to their Jewish
communities their minority communities
often
in the Jewish Community case what
happened in the Holocaust to confront
that yes Nazi Germany was primarily
responsible but what about their own
responsibilities and every nation in the
world I think you'd have to say has some
responsibility no one acted perfectly in
those years when you don't confront
history we generally find that the
regimes are have more difficulty in and
confronting the problem and that's good
and bad we'd like the regimes always to
be obviously every government to have an
attitude of we have some problem and
there is a problem to a lesser greater
degree in almost every country in Europe
with
anti-Semitism and we'd like everybody to
say yes we have a problem and we want to
have policies that confronted but
frankly from a US policy perspective
it's sometimes easier for us to be able
to make some changes and help those
communities when we have problematic
situations with the government where it
doesn't want or for whatever reason is
not dealing with the issue because then
there's one address you can go to at
least at least one address you there's
always multiple addresses you have to go
to to try to begin to get handle on this
problem uh but you then have a really
important address it's like I use
historical analogies the Soviet jewelry
movement in that case it almost makes uh
it seems very simple to the problem we
face with anti-Semitism in Europe today
because there was one address and it was
the Kremlin that we could address to
try to begin to fix that problem here
there's all always and that's why I
talked about complexity to begin there's
within one country multiple multiple
addresses often and between countries
the nature of anti-Semitism often there
are similarities but it's often very
different so uh all that's to say the
way we look at this is to see what's
happening with the community try to find
NES often data but often anecdotal and
interviews and then uh we look at what
the government's trying to do and
sometimes again our our tools are better
when uh the government is not as as uh
on top of the issue as we'd like um
thank you for that I want to uh
reference a a question and tie it to a a
phenomenon I'm thinking the phenomenon
the Ukraine uh a very murky complex
phenomenon but with some uh very
upsetting rhetoric yeah uh and uh events
reported uh this can be linked to a
question that c comes from Washington DC
from Janine who said that she read that
Germany and Poland are the safest places
for Jews two countries that have done
differing levels but real levels of
confronting history in your sense uh Ira
uh so she says they're the safest places
for Jew she read um is this true and uh
does it offer any model for other uh
countries in the European Union Philip
Roth would agree with that pardon Philip
Roth the writer he would agree with yes
because because he he wrote a book
operation suggesting that Jews
need to go from Israel to Germany and
Poland because those would be the places
where nothing would happen for another
thousand years you know so that's Philip
Ro I don't know what IRA has to say well
I
um I I think it's hard to say which is
the absolute safest place to be as a Jew
in Europe today um Berlin Berlin perhaps
but the UK which has problems has very
strong Jewish institutions and like
Germany there's maybe even an increase
in Jewish population now Germany clearly
is increasing in population but the UK
May slowly be adding some Jews as well
um and Poland is a very interesting
place uh you do see a lot of
anti-Semitism how it's manifested is
often different the violence you don't
see the violence you might see in parts
of Western Europe uh and you also have a
lot of uh very philosemitic views and
and you hear it and it's really touching
in some ways when you look at
institutions like the galatian Jewish
Museum and you see that all the staff is
Polish Catholic and when you talk to
them often I've heard responses like I'm
doing this because we lost something
really precious when we lost 10% of our
population a a cultural piece that we
are trying to retain at least a little
bit
of uh and I think that's a lesson for
all countries a lot of countries
um that are concerned often their
nationalism sometimes takes a form which
if you're not that ethnicity of that
Nation somehow you're polluting that
nation and you they would like to see a
monoculture and I think what we see in
that response from like Poland polish uh
Catholics is that actually the
Multicultural Society is much richer you
look at some of these countries in the
Middle East Arab states that are lose
have lost their Jewish population and
now in the process of losing their
Christian chrisan population and
tragedies for the Jewish communities
that left tragedies for these Christian
communities that are under pressure but
I think ultimately tragedies for the
countries themselves so um I think those
are important issues it's hard getting
back to your initial question very hard
to say which is the safest places but I
think we've talked a little bit of few
you mentioned Ukraine which I think is
fascinating I've been to Ukraine twice
in the year I've been here both before
maidon and after maidon and it's a some
really interesting changes first we all
have to acknowledge there's a lot of um
Jewish blood there's a lot of
anti-Semitism in Ukrainian
history uh and we've heard particularly
since my Dawn began uh from particularly
Moscow that there is a lot lots of uh
Ukrainian anti-semitic nationality the
government's problematic there's
anti-Semitism in keev in the government
and what I found when I went back last
month was was not that talking to Jewish
Community leaders uh I got as far east
as I could it was as Neo Petros and
essentially unanimously saying we these
incidents that we have in most cases we
don't know who did it some cases we
do but even when we don't know we
believe they're provocations they're
Happening by and large in the west of
the eastern part of the country which is
not the center of Ukrainian nationalism
uh that has an anti-semitic
ttin uh we and I when I talked to
government officials when I went back to
keev this time Kev or keev depending
whether you're saying Russian or
Ukrainian uh when I went back the line I
got from government officials who were
members of the party of regions who was
ruling prior to
maidon the line I got almost unanimously
was we have no anti-Semitism in
Ukraine and I Polly would say to them
that's not credible we have
anti-Semitism in United States and we we
are probably the friendliest country by
far in the world possible exception of
Israel uh to our Jewish
population and uh we have no
anti-Semitism this time I hear a
government saying government officials
often the exact same offices and
sometimes the junior people in that room
are the same people because they haven't
changed and they're saying yes we have a
history history and yes if we're going
to have a successful modern Ukraine
we're going to confront this and we have
to confront it because it's a part of
our Rich history very different response
and the Jewish Community says we see
what we what you hear about in the west
We Believe even when we don't know for
sure who did it it's provocations and
it's not coming from the government it's
not even coming from the nationalists in
uh like a like private sector or uh
what's called saot another party that
historically has antiem Roots so um
fascinating Dynamic there and despite
the history of Ukraine you actually even
see some um optimism the Jewish
Community interesting you you pleas go
sorry um I I was really interested in in
um one comment that you made about um
whether or not the term anti-Semitism
applies to certain
situations um so what did you mean by
that because I I think I know um but I'd
like to hear it from you um
so uh to call someone an
anti-semite essentially ends your
conversation you've as I like to say you
call someone an anti-semite you've hit
them in the face with a
2x4 now sometimes it's appropriate it's
clear Etc and sometimes appropriate
sometimes in terms of certainly personal
uh what's going on in that person's mind
you don't know you can say what they're
saying we we interpret as
anti-Semitism uh we talked about those
delegitimization defamation type of
issues but sometimes you want to have a
conversation and sometimes saying this
we don't believe this is legitimate we
believe this cross the line is a better
way I believe to continue to have that
conversation so um I don't think
combating anti-Semitism means
necessarily that you say say this is
anti-Semitic or you're an anti-semitic
the more most times you can I think
that's got to be the way we combat this
has got to be both complex and often
subtle and sometimes it's quite
appropriate to say sometimes it may not
be best to try to get to the where you
want to
go someone I just to give an example
Roya we are talking about circumcision
if someone like the six Nordic udman
uh for
children uh have said that they have
come out for a ban of circumcision in
their countries and they say it's
because of children's autonomy and other
people say it's because um the of uh
that the risks are so terrible and the
Ben there's no
benefits uh so I don't think it would no
matter what I think someone may be
feeling if someone's saying that I'm not
I'm going to make my arguments on
religious freedom I'm I'm not going to
say this is anti-Semitic or islamophobic
for that matter I think it's really
important to say to take that at their
word and say okay this is an issue of
religious freedom and though so you're
making the
argument uh children have pain that
persists psychologically through their
lifetime you're making the argument
risks are far outweighing and they are
are great and benefits are no and I say
okay let's have that argument on
religious freedom grounds and on
religious freedom grounds we don't
protect all forms of religious activity
we say is there a compelling State
interest to stop that
form so I would then come back and if
people who are making that argument and
say okay uh our largest studies for
example the American pediatri Academy of
Pediatrics would say that benefits clear
benefits far far outweigh risks Mayo
clinics this um publication this past
month say benefits outweigh risk 100 to
one and and there are no studies
whatsoever there's no indication that
there's any permanent uh traumatic pain
and uh so where's the compelling State
interest and religious freedom is now
being o o o
overturned without a compell any kind of
compelling interests so that's the
argument we need to make and I don't
think throwing around terms of
anti-Semitism when someone's claiming uh
another reason is going to be useful I
I'm hearing uh a certain utility that I
didn't anticipate as I listened to each
of you talk about anti-Semitism and the
fact that it's uh become a factor inside
of the United States uh Department of
State is quite interesting and and fills
uh suggests a number of possibilities
one of which finds expression in a
question that comes from uh the
Democracy Challenge online community uh
which asks how can anti-Semitism and
racism hurt emerging democracies and
then a follow-up question which I think
each of you might address why is
diversity beneficial to a democracy um
you want to start off on that right sure
um um I was really intrigued by um Ira's
comments on U Poland and and why um you
know these Catholic polish individuals
were so concerned about the loss of the
Jewish Community um I have heard similar
comments from within the Iranian
Community um people who um are very
patriotic about Iran uh constantly say
that um losing the Jewish community of
Iran would be a major loss to to Iran
period that um not only historically the
Jewish Community uh the Jewish
community's existence precedes that of
the Muslim Community that Jews have been
there before the Advent of Islam but
that um it it is that the existence of
of a unique community that gives uh Iran
its unique character of course you you
know if the regime were wise it could
begin to think economically about it
because the the most sacred Jewish sites
in the Middle East outside of Israel are
in Iran um and you could have a thriving
tour tourism uh business out of just
taking Jewish uh tourists to it CHS the
way on that doesn't it yes yes and and
so um there there is a very strong
argument to make for Iran uh which H
which clearly isn't an Arab country
Iranians really Pride themselves um on
the notion of being Persians and being
non-arabs and and one of the factors
that makes the Persians Persians is the
notion that we are the Civilized more
tolerant ones at least according to the
Persian narrative uh and we are the ones
and and what backs up that claim is that
we are the ones that have been
ethnically and religiously diverse
because we can tolerate whereas those
people on the other side of the borders
can't and and so um you want to prove um
I think it was third Good Marshall uh
who said that you know the the quality
of any democracy can be observed by uh
the quality of the lives of the most
vulnerable minorities within those
democracies that that in fact if you
want to measure
uh whether a democracy is truly a
democracy um you look at how the most
vulnerable minorities are existing uh
within those democracies and and I think
the reason Iran or any other country uh
would want to hang on to his Jewish
Community um if for no other reason than
to prove that it's a serious democracy
is because you want to show that you are
able to cope and and live in peace with
your minorities and you are are U
capable of taking care of um of the
vulnerable um which which I think uh
Iran in Iran today Jews and other
religious minorities definitely are I I
feel that I I must say um that we keep
talking about Jews in Iran and I
certainly don't want to convey the idea
that the um that Jews are the only
threatened minority in Iran that that in
fact um it's you would probably live a a
worse life in Iran if you were a Sunni
in Iran today um is there a Sunni
population in 10% um I think and and
sunnis are not allowed to build mosques
in Iran um and you know sunnis have a
much harder uh time of being religiously
free in Iran than than Jews have so I
think you know in the interest of being
um Fair and balanced uh we should
mention that there are um other
religious minorities in Iran who who
have a much harder time and are far more
seriously persecuted uh than the Jews
are so you're suggesting that the
treatment of that the afford of the Jews
has implications for other uh vulnerable
communities absolutely in in in Iran
perhaps elsewhere as well any comments
on that Ira well I'm I would agree with
uh with much of what Roya has said I am
not an academic that can point to
statistic ICS and data that would say a
Multicultural Society is more beneficial
I think we have a strong bias where I
work in the US state department uh for
many reasons that Multicultural
societies are stronger uh certainly our
own history our
multiculturalism it's been a long and
difficult path often and is not always
totally complete but we've had I think
we around the world where I go people
are marveling at our example where we
have come to uh and so there's almost
there's a w a a wishfulness by people
who will believe in Democratic
principles Etc to be able how do we
follow the US model um so I think we
certainly have that bias whether I can
prove it academically or not that that's
uh that's a stronger Society I think we
strongly feel that and I think uh
there's a lot of historical
um uh analogies we can use I love the
story of the Ottoman the Sultan of the
Ottoman Empire in
1492 questioning what kind of king and
queen meaning Ferdinand and Isabella
would kick out their most productive
members of their society I'm happy to
take them and he
did uh I'm uh I I'm fascinated when I
was in Greece recently where conspiracy
theories and the protocols the Elders of
Zion are ubiquitous and Golden Dawn is
a a Neo-Nazi deeply anti-semitic deeply
violent party in Parliament uh talking
to NOS who say you know part of some
some ways that people now in Greece
interpret uh helenic civilization uh
Greek nationalism is to say we were a
pure kind of ethnicity and race and so
all these forers not just Jews but all
these more importantly the refugees
coming in from Asia and Africa they're
polluting our our Greek civilization and
the irony of that that
helenismo the height of Greek culture
and the Greek n nationalism and the
other irony is this whether we think
Multicultural societies are good or not
and we all I think in this panel
certainly think strongly that they are
it's happening in this modern world
world with economics Etc a country like
Greece is going to be Multicultural
there's no way going back and I think
most governments in Europe understand
that that it's inevitable so how do we
live with that and take its strengths
and integrate uh different uh groups
that are coming in so I think that's a
powerful piece and and I I'm proud the
United States sometimes sometimes can
serve as a model in this
area rather than taking the risk of on
that upbeat hope I I do wish to note
that that anti-Semitism has been called
the longest hatred um and there's a
question from our live audience that
emerges from that sense is anti-Semitism
ineradicable and why in any case is it
so persistent perhaps each of you might
care to comment on
that
um I think I I often think about U
anti-Semitism in relationship to
misogyny because um I experienced both
and um I write often as I impose on you
to read um about the fact that I think
the problem uh that we in the west have
identified as uh Islamic fundamentalism
in the Middle East is um is only
disguising itself as Islamic
fundamentalism it's actually misogyny um
the there that that wishes to cloak
itself behind uh the look of U Islamic
fundamentalism because once we um label
it as Islam everybody else in the west
says well this is their tradition and
their religion and we can have nothing
to do with it and we can't intervene and
we can't it's their thing uh but if we
call it misogyny which I think what it
is um truly uh then then we can
intervene because we believe in human
rights and and we believe
in um
that these rights should be afforded to
to all people around the world that that
you know um for the same reason that
people because of their virtue of their
race shouldn't be uh treated as lesser
people um they also shouldn't be uh
treated at Le as lesser people for the
virtue of their gender um so um I see
them as as I see misogyny and I see
anti-Semitism because of my own personal
experience as um being um uh the two
sides of the same coin and um and that's
that's a long argument but I think in in
in relationship to to the Middle East it
certainly applies um and I think these
are not uh at least In Our Lifetime or
in my lifetime uh problems that can be
eradicated but they're problems that um
uh that can be that can fade uh with uh
the sort of strides that a society makes
as a whole um if you there was something
very interesting in in the ADL
survey uh that came out and and uh with
a friend who's much uh more of a
historian than I am U we sat down to
look at the details of the ADL numbers
um with respect to Iran and and uh
something that was very remarkable uh
about the ADL survey uh with respect to
IR on was that um it had the lowest
numbers of people who believe that Jews
are making too much of the Holocaust in
the Middle East um and and so we started
uh with with this friend discussing it
was only 18% I believe so 18% of
Iranians U believe that Jews were um
were making too much of the Holocaust
and and had a hard time letting it go um
and so we we thought w why
should then for the same question
anywhere else in the Middle East people
say you know be stand at 70% and 80% and
Iran would be 18 well part of that is
because uh Iran
is we had we had a president in Iran who
was completely unloved at least during
his second term of presidency um against
whom the population turned and that was
you know the the green movement in Iran
in 2009
where where people believed that that
the election had been stolen from them
poured to the streets took um you know
um demonstrated against Ahmed NAD and
underwent that process of rising up
standing against the Tyrant speaking up
um had it was it was an educational
process because they began to also
question his platform and his propaganda
at a Cornerstone of which was the denial
of the Holocaust so so I think
societies uh in the process of reaching
for greater civil liberties equality
freedom and
democracy undergo whether they want it
or not uh a a a reform in or an
education in
anti-Semitism um and and other um you
know uh afflictions such as misogyny uh
and racism and etc etc and in in Iran
the reason now we see that a only 18% of
the population um believe that the
Holocaust is something that the Jews
can't let go uh is
because five years after Ahmed NAD um
the fact that the nation had to confront
this President and together think
through his entire propaganda Machinery
of was a major point of education and I
think each time um we do one of these
things um as as people um we take a step
back um from anti-Semitism from misogyny
and from all these um terrible things
that we are trying to uh do away with
thank you for that Roy uh IA do you have
any concluding remarks on uh this
question of eradicating anti- yeah the
ineradicable or possibly radical uh
hatred well I I don't know the answer to
the question of whether anti-Semitism
will ever be
eradicated uh I again I I always like to
look at history as kind of a little bit
of a guidepost and we can see that in
history we can go back at least 2,300
years or so and see forms of
anti-Semitism we can see anti-Semitism
morphing into different
forms uh often with different arguments
but with some basic uh principles behind
it we see it today in in Europe and
other
places uh so this is what I do think I
don't think that uh we will see the end
of anti-Semitism in my lifetime or in my
children's lifetime or my
grandchildren's or many many many many
generations but I don't think that's the
key
question uh I think certainly in the
Jewish tradition and I think in other
Traditions uh the issue is not do can we
eradicate evil
um the
issue
remains we have to fight against it we
have to give future Generations tools to
fight against it we have to make it
better whether we eradicate or not
history will F tell us eventually um I
don't expect it anytime
soon uh but our job is here to to fight
it with every means we have and do it in
the smartest uh most effective way we
have
beautiful thank you I think we can
conclude here if you have additional
questions I'm speaking to uh people
online and and here we are happy to
continue the conversation online we'll
continue to monitor the hashtag uh
stateof rights on Twitter and Converse
with you there this event will be
archived and made available on public on
uh humanrights.gov in the coming few
days special thank you to Yale
University and the program for the study
of anti-Semitism us Department of State
for co-hosting this discussion and thank
you to everybody who participated today
thank you thank you Rabbi thank
you you Ed like